o vooz pessoal domingos a mais um vídeo
e hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma sopa
que eu to the waltz que vocês tanto
pediram nos comentários
e ela é muito boa mesmo só consegue para
vários tipos de munições à distância e
altura que vocês quiserem
é tanta distância nunca passou dos 10
metros que é mais ou menos 10 metros o
máximo dela e como é que vocês ajustam e
pronto a altura eo al quer quanto mais
vocês puxam que é para trás mais alta e
mais longe vai se vocês quiserem
aumentar um pouquinho mais ostensivo e
orlando corda na frente quanto mais
regular e mais alto e mais longe eu te
pago vai cair
só que não foi muito porque o objetivo é
que manda extinto os objetos mas muito
paralelo ao chão
foi como ela foi concebida originalmente
mito na idade média
um cliente um submarino da chuva então
vamos fazer que catapulta se vocês
quiserem fazer o link do tempo diz a
descrição vocês carregam lá você tem
direcionado para nova lei disse que
basicamente alguém roubou minha palavra
passe e estou fazer uma nova e lá você
encontra um pronto coisa gente de optar
os vídeos fotos e contestou fazemos
projetos e coisas do gênero e eu vou
passar tudo da antiga para a nova fase
pra isso aqui então vamos lá em primeiro
está tudo pronto vocês começarem usado
políticos e os proventos genome mudam
queria o tema em deus no meu caso por
ter menos eu tenho dá tempo aos
políticos mas cansou se voz potente foi
maior
é só ajustar em 4 deus vocês vão fazer
quatro políticos que encaixem naquela
partida não está vindo a cair
o resto não vai ser preciso porque é só
cortar só cortar e mostrei como cortar e
potente que é sempre a mesma coisa
encaixe em que os laranjas no lugar dos
lados vejam que faz 90 graus culpa muito
grande é muito importante
podem orientar pelos ano pronto do
partido laranja do modo que tem que
ficar sobre o posto estiver então fica
aí encaixem os vermelhos estar mesmo ali
à frente do queniano encostado ao outro
paulinho fica um pequeno procedimento
entre os pontinhos vermelhos e para eu
conseguir depois por um ou mais e
preenche e usain bolt disputada e
atenção como você escolhe quem corta um
é o corta luz de nossa parte nunca
contra a vossa mão é sempre na direção
oposta
vai ficar essa parte limpa o fundo cola
e atenção não punham cola muito perto
até que os pensamentos puserem quando
apertar o conflito vai entrar lá pra
dentro e vai ser muito complicado pois
vocês tirarem ou até mais este pontinho
que vão marcar aqui é lugar para
encaixar ali aquela parte pra cima e
esse lugar fica em cima dos pensamentos
para estar 2 verde eo laranja e cola de
modo em que façam 90 graus entre o
laranja eo verde e que assim uma espécie
de cerca aquelas proteções na estrada
cola no lugar é simulado celular
só com uma coisa é que nunca venha para
tem que cumprir um dos planos de
filmagem e e laranja ali na frente então
como é que vocês primeiro colo chi
primários e por escola o varejo à frente
para ti que tudo encaixado mesmo se não
for aqui os dois por maio
ele não vai aguentar a catapulta
enquanto o impacto da criança que já fiz
a colher conquistar aqui do oeste como
tinha de ter um pouquinho disputada
vocês podem usar pouco entende só que
não fique muito resistente
aí você não tiver outra opção que vai
mesmo causar espanto de um elástico mais
fraca caiu então foi um clímax no lar
vocês vão ver que eu queria pois é só
colar e retenção tem que rolar mesmo
ponto porque escolar e muito trabalho
empurrarem esta quarta o pau de colher
vai bater no chão e não vai rodar o
plástico é só ajustar o tamanho que o
poder da frente passando pelo passamento
olinda colher e encaixa ali não tem
melhor o amarelo
aí vocês querem o quê momento melhor
pessoal podem usar uma cola para a
madeira uma cola rápido fica muito
melhor
mas atenção se vocês forem crianças
peçam joãozinho também nos nessas
escolas e só chegamos ao fim se vocês
quiserem dar o canal de xingó shopping o
vosso brito se inscrevam para acompanhar
as coisas que eu faço é aí claro achei
mais distante que eu fazendo sempre que
você deixe nos comentários
em solo e super rápida quando era
pequenininha fazer de tudo para ter em
castelos foi de pecinhas de domínio
emitir mesmo vocês verem que tudo é de
montar
então ele só vai te ao i